hello everyone and welcome back to the
world blitz championship it's a bottle
of Java versus magnus carlsen after
Coulson's drawn against abdul Sattar of
in round six he had his first loss since
he arrived in this championship there's
a b3 already on the board and well he
losted Metreon Dracon and then he
quickly bounced back with an another win
against chocolate Momiji I think I don't
think Magnus ever lost a blitz game to
Mammadov
I could be wrong but he has like a
really insane score when it comes to
blitz games but here it's bothered Obama
who is always a very exciting player
regardless of the time format and who is
especially deadly with the white pieces
so let's see this game and what it's all
about
now as obama goes for b3 the names of
arson attack we have g6 by magnus Bishop
to b2 at Knight to f6 now and here comes
the Bishop Tadros n f6 a very rare
system that I've never actually seen
anyone play especially in such a
top-tier competition but that's why
they're here and it's a blitz game so e
captures on f6 and now C for Magnus
replies with the d5 we have C captors on
d5 Queen captures on d5 and Knight to c3
developing with tempo the queen is under
attack Queen back to a5 and now a three
now with ideas of pushing the Queen even
further back would be for at some point
we have c6 preparing this well maneuver
to bring the Queen back if needed
III and now there is a game where Bishop
to g7 was played and Bishop to f5 but
here with f5 by Magnus and it is already
as I'm away that we have a completely
new game so J Bhabha continues with g3
Bishop to d6 Magnus continues
development Bishop to g2 and not nice to
d7 going for for f6 where the night will
be will be able to go either to e4 g for
a depending on what black place even d5
with Knight gt2 and Knight to f6 now and
George Ababa castles Magnus castles and
now finally before taking the Queen back
to the starting square Queen back to be
eight and here comes d4 it's okay the
position is pretty
you know becoming a normal one Queen to
e7 by Magnus developing the queen now
the bishop and the rooks will be
developed rook to be one preparing b5
and here Magnus even forces it with a
three which a five which is a good
decision since
well if b5 is played then you grab the a
three point and you create a past a
point which is what Coulson wants but
Jabba doesn't mind he pushes b5 we have
Bishop captures on a three pawn
caspere's and c6 pawn captures and
Bishop captures on c6 so it's a trade
Magnus has is outside past a point where
Azure Bala has a past deep on so we're
we're gonna see who's pawns are faster
we looked at a six attacking the bishop
and here a nice trick by Jabba a Knight
to d5 which saves the bishop and also
forces a trade here now as the Queen is
under attack
so Knight captures Bishop characters and
Bishop to b4 now taking away the c3
square from the White Knight and also
preventing the rook from doing any any
lifting here we have Knight to f4 by Joe
baba and push on the back to d6 now we
have Queen to f3 so if the knight is
captured you can capture back with the
Queen and a for now now Magnus starts
pushing his past a pawn with rook F to
c1 and now even a three and here Bishop
to a 2 this is the blockades Obama
wanted to create the bishop will not
prevent the point from being pushed any
further the rooks are nicely placed on
open a B and C files the knight is on an
excellent f4 square and the Queen can
pretty much go wherever she wants so we
have looked the a7 the rook will be
helpful with the defense of the 7th rank
and Knight to d5 now the Queen is under
attack and you want to keep an eye on
the f6 square so Queen to d8 and now h4
Jabba is coming for Magnus with Bishop
to e6 now countering White's light
square Bishop and King to g2 it's a bit
maybe a bit dangerous to put the king
and queen on the same diagonal as
Carlsen still has a light square bishop
but it would take him some moves the
tori maneuver leadership over there and
the Jabba has plans of just trading it
off so h5 Magnus doesn't allow Jabbar to
push h5 and Knight back to sea
three now offering a trade of light
square bishop s-- with the shop captures
night captures and now rook the c7
carlson wants to trade down and enjoy
his past a three pawn queen to d5 and
now queen today eight offering a queen
trade here
Joba trades with Queen Catherine a8 rook
captures and now rook captures on c7 we
have bunch of characters on c7 and now
it's an endgame the position is really
really wild the the material on the
board is equal but it's a bishop against
tonight and we do have play on both
sides of the board which means that
black should be a little bit better here
King to f3 already you have to start
activating your king you cannot go
through through here because the pawns
the pawn and Bishop cover now I create a
wall against the white king so King f8
we have King back to e 2 you're gonna go
up the board this way Magnus will do the
same but first Bishop d6 defend the pawn
so now the rook can be activated King to
d3 and now King e7 with rook to b7 with
Chuck just King e6 we have rook to b6
pinning the bishop and we have looked at
a 7 now now the King will use the
seventh ranked to approach the rook on
d6 King to see to the white king is now
approaching the pawn king d7 now with
King Tubby one and now kink the c7
pushing the rook back rook the B 3 and
now Magnus very confident in his endgame
still skills decides that he wants the
trade rooks here
so King c2 if the trade happens Jabbar
wants his King to be on a bit more
active square-root captures with King
characters and now King to c6
we have Knight to c3 now Jabbar creates
a wall against the cross and skin here
as you will not be able to approach the
position and Magnus goes f6 he wants to
push g5 so here it's the like I said
it's the the game is on both sides of
the board so Bishop is a bit better than
night but cousin has a double F pawn so
that goes into Baba's favor King to see
for the night nicely guards d8 u square
and now g5 by Magnus and of course our
Joe Baba doesn't want to end of all
calls and spawn so he pushes f4 and
Magnus and doesn't mind closing the
position since all of the points here
are on dark
squares and Magnus has a dark square
bishop so here King Tubby 3 and Magnus
just plays it back to f8 and you know
realistically you should you you can
agree to a draw here if you if you put
this to any computer it will just tell
you 0 0 0 but that's easier said than
said and done this is a blitz game both
of them are very long time and you know
the clock is ticking so here King to c4
you just you know prevent the the black
King from approaching your Kings on a
nice light squared the knight guards dat
pawn nothing is happening here however
after Carlson's Bishop to f8 move Jabbar
play Knight to be 1 which means that he
should win this pawn and after he wants
the pawn he's up upon and well could be
could be even winning problem is this
little maneuver cost him the game so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it this this legend they removed
the title speaks off while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those who were
able to do it congratulations and if you
pause the video and found it you are an
excellent spotter of legendary moves and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show its Bishop to b4 and it's
interesting
Magnus played this move instantly so he
I think he kind of played Bishop to f8
to trying to try and trigger Bawa so
here the problem is if you capture the
bishop a two wins there's nothing you
can do next move a if you move the
knight just a one Queen if you don't
just pawn captures with Queen on the
other hand if you don't if you play
Knight captures on a three then the
bishop infiltrates the shop T 1 and you
eliminate all of the black points and
then you just Queen the h-bond so Joe
Baba said okay a nice little trick but
I'm not interested nice to see 3 however
this doesn't help your ball here Magnus
just continues with a 2 it's again the
same problem if you play king characters
and Bishop characters and you win a
piece now you're completely winning so
after a - Joe baba had to play Knight
captures an a2 but now Bishop the e1 and
this is where things go really wrong for
Joe valla
he played King c4 but now it's just you
know a feast for this dark square Bishop
Bishop characters and g3
not before check with King d6 King to d3
now
of characters on h4 now you have two
connected passed pawns that's just
deadly efore we have captures with check
captures and Bishop to g3 and now Joe
Bell played f4 here but Magnus played h4
with Knight to d5 and here Magnus just
played h3 and it was in this position
that Butler Bala resigned the game as
the H ponies queening and there's
nothing you can do about it
the Bishop and pawn create a wall here
well not like that but like this against
the White King so the White King is
helpless in helping out with the
preventing you the pond from queening
and if you do anything else like
characters h2 you can even capture this
one but still the new queen with check
anyway if he didn't Queen which check
won't really matter but there are no
tricks and Jabba resigns so impressive
game and when he had everything he just
had to play King to c4 but then you know
it's it's it's it's what they call the
Magnus effect from nothing something
happens so that's one of the games I
also decided to show you I do hope you
enjoyed it and do remember this little
tactic if it happens in your own games
you know avoid it and if you can use it
to win then win a lot of games using it
I would like to thank the Dahle Borya
coming for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World
Championship for the next next two days
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday